[Music]
we are in the middle of a big change
Transportation it's going to be very
different from what we know now when you
build it they will come when you build
the bike planes microability will come
it will be revolutionary and I think
Israel is in the front of the resolution
[Music]
Tel Aviv is very very friendly for micro
Mobility which has been bicycle and
e-bike and the east hotel it's a very
flat City so it's very easy to bike here
already we have 170
000 biking a day and from that 35
000 are the shirts quarter and the rest
is private high-tech transportation is
changing the face of Tel Aviv quite
literally
the city is lying with bike Lanes
electric scooter spaces and people
walking all around
but it hasn't always been like this
when I started in consultation we
decided to make a vision how we look at
it for the next 20 years and the first
thing was to make an esthetic plan about
sustainable Transportation how we look
at that traffic congestion is the second
largest cause of worsening emissions in
Israel
and Tel Aviv itself ranks as the 16th
most congested city in the world
which is why reducing pollutants and
creating Transportation Alternatives has
become a focal point in the city's
strategy all the city is rebuilding so
it will be suitable in The Last Mile for
public transportation and Miko Mobility
we made the map where we want the micro
Mobility to be where do we want them to
move we rebuild about 160 kilometer of
bike line so micro mobility and the car
can be mixed together in the same state
we make more places for workability so
there is straight that we decide that
there is no enter for car and it's open
for more business to open their chairs
and tables it's more comfortable and
more clean air and less noisy
you know they used to say that the best
ideas come in the shower
so for me the best ideas come when I
ride in the boardwalk
from my house to Jaffa
to me there's no reason why in large
congested cities
people should use cards
bird is literally transformed the city
in the past four years we had over 10
million rides over 550
000 unique users if you walk around the
city you see how many bike Lanes have
been created since we started to operate
in terms of the demographics everybody
uses them I'm riding scooter I'm riding
bike I'm riding motorcycle I write about
everything that moved
[Music]
the biggest concern is obviously safety
in the past four years we've gone
through an education process Tel Aviv
has had some of the earliest and
strongest scooter regulations like
licenses being contingent on mandatory
helmet use and operators being 18 or
older but they still cause accidents
it's raised a lot of questions on what's
needed to keep people safe
we have to regulate the speed to
maintain safety more people wear helmets
right in the right places and we need
more enforcement that's very important
in Fleet like Tel Aviv that have many
people walking many car driving
[Music]
Israelis by their nature are early
adopters and they're innovators there's
a reason why Israel is called startup
Nation so when they see a solution to a
problem they go for it this idea of a
startup nation is pretty prevalent in
Tel Aviv and it goes beyond
Transportation the city has been
attracting high-tech workers for years
over the past decade the number of
startups has reached 3 000 and the
number of multinational research and
development centers has tripled to 115.
the very young people people that work
in the high tech we are a startup City
and those are the community that like to
bike
the vision of the city of Tel Aviv is
remarkable by 2025 the goal is to have
over 25 percent of bribes in Tel Aviv
being by micro Mobility that is
unparalleled to any other place in the
world
whatever I see many is hotel and bike
riders I say well those was supposed to
be car driver and they give up the car
and they move to the alternative
[Music]
foreign